I really appreciate that very very very
kind thank you
that's lovely right back at you it's
important you know we all want to this
is a no I want to hold this now I
thought well I think it killed
everything you can use it yeah yeah this
is not only for us it's a PSA it's like
a public service we're trying to help
the people yeah you got to wash your
hands this is what I know you got to
wash your hands frequently yeah for 20
seconds right which by the way it's
exhausting
have you tried I mean like my forearms
are killing me yeah
if armwrestling comes back I'm ready
yeah it's a lot 20 seconds it's a lot
longer than you think that's what I just
said and then the other thing Conan and
this is important is if I understand it
correctly
don't touch people's faces right they
say don't touch people's faces
yes well such your own face oh it's your
own face it's your own face yeah what
were you doing before you got the ones
easier yeah yeah
guys were screwed don't touch your face
yeah difficult it is very hard that's a
rule in a drinking game yeah that's how
difficult to do it is very hard to do
especially if one is admires one's face
I'm a bit of a face touch her I like to
the cheekbones that you know I mean I'm
gonna move on okay let me tell you
something you pointed me while wearing a
hat yes you had nothing to do but you
stopped you stopped the flow of a
professional show you stopped the bus
and then you had nothing the way
sneakiness lay hoping for a bird to land
on here I try to pay attention I think I
heard it I just can't keep up it's
alright it's alright alright so here's
the deal speaking of a break in the flow
yeah I came on your podcast I want to
talk about this
yes yeah this is perfect because a
little bit of a bone to pick with you I
have a podcast that's not doing this and
he's not doing the travel thing and then
there's the knitting show got a lot of
stuff going you know it's really
important to keep a lot of things going
wait to hear about the children that we
don't know about you think that's why
I'm doing that can't figure out why
there's no way to if I had a secret
child
everyone would be a six foot four a girl
with a pompadour walking around
there's no way I'm hiding a secret kid
all right
if anyway you this guy comes on my
podcast and hilarya wonderful guy but
then he keeps interrupting me to do
commercials for his own stuff you start
doing commercials for products that
you're promoting you interrupted me like
15 times to promote your stuff I've
never seen anyone do that before and I
want you to know that I'm not going to
do that tonight I'm not I don't want to
I promise you I don't want to interrupt
the flow of the thing because I felt
like that was one of the things that was
a little bit of a problem
yeah so I won't do that and the answer
to your first question will be brought
to you by granik's Apple bitter spray
it's a spray your dogs and cats hate and
you can spray it in their mouths if you
need to or you just spray sit up on your
furniture fantastic continue are you
getting money from them you're getting
actual money from the grant instead they
said if you do it on the show it's way
more than the podcast
[Laughter]
and people spray what are you here to
promote besides this product that you
just mentioned what do you really hear
get into it just wring them out okay you
want to get your long net right now
no no I just thought maybe you've got
something going I just didn't want to
break the flow so I just wanted to throw
it out there now you can ask you a
question and it's brought to you by
granik's a bitter spray all right I
wouldn't buy anything from that man
you don't look trustworthy